guys it would not be a day with cat
Alvarado unless we checked out some dark
related video I don't know why you got
on this train with me but it's it's just
makes me happy it's always the last
video we shoot we go through some really
uplifting stuff but always like before
she leaves this apartment that's our
intro that's cat Alvarado sear on social
media I'm Greg Alva welcome to the real
rejects I'm gonna give a patron the day
this is someone at the end of this video
so tune in find out if it's you who
earned it oh yeah this disturbing movies
you won't be able to sit through is no
stranger to movies Austin proof that
beyond a shadow of a doubt interned his
name into a synonym for over-the-top
violence it the green firm but what
pushes things further than ever before
and unless you're a seasoned go hands
chances I won't make it to the end in
the grand tradition of the video nasties
of the seventies and eighties
[Music]
the whole population doesn't see the
actors were all paid film and while they
didn't have much experience in front of
the camera they saw that right away
and
[Applause]
don't okay 2008 French both movies have
roughly the same plot but there's one
big difference the english-language
version is remarkably tank
despite its inherently unsettling
subject that's by design
right amok Elson it told creating
screenwriting I'm not a lover of
violence I try to stay away from all the
violence and keep it off screen which
was kind of the polar opposite of the
rich desire if you've got a low
tolerance for abuse and still when it's
screened it can audiences let's put the
disc in gross they just couldn't handle
it for the best this horrifying climax
it's easy to understand why sure modest
is also a nuanced story about yeltsin
friendship
this myth is right when he says that
there's more to it than me gold the gore
is a big part of like the New York Times
wrote this isn't one fan manages
everything oh no I would never watch
this never never never
that's not the only reason over 250
people fled from the film's premiere
with many fighting or seeking medical
treatment the sound played a big role to
see your reversible uses interest motor
frequency sound waves to augment it
sunset visions you can't actually hear
this but your body registers in any way
leading to feelings of anxiety bunnies
distress and depression in addition to
the shivers and sometimes
nausea it's sort of an anxiety producing
I don't know about fear but it's
unnerving it's a trick that many modern
horror games use in paranormal activity
well it doesn't effect
every member of the audience here is
Sangha it's credited as one of the
reasons why irreversible makes many
members of its audience feel sick in
fact many people who watch don't even
make it very far into the development
actors have ever watched is really hot
they are irreversible this might not do
not some many viewers before it's the
most horrific action even truly begins
when the woman made mistake many know
what basically wished they had but
indications that's exactly the type of
reaction director Lucky McKee whose
whole family's attempt to civilize a
wild lucky here in the basement and
torturing her is explicitly designed to
push every misogynistic and toxically
masculine but oddly at least once you
get past my service shocks it's not all
gore and blood the woman has something
to say it also has a pretty decent one
tomorrow school especially for this
country there's a rewarding experience
this company
tired this movie was great yeah has its
name to erased
anything goes unfortunately no everyone
got the memo and one fan found corley
logics revenge so intense that he had a
seizure a lot in the middle of the
theater reportedly it was a
stomach-churning scene which a man is
forced to remove a piece of glass from
his foot that didn't thought Jack told
anyone we started to hear someone say
hello hello from the audience I didn't
know if it was someone making a joke in
the bird then I see the paramedics in
the cinema the audience member was fine
he was a good company to revenge Lee
Matilda Lutz admitted the same made her
feel weird as well when she was there in
the same shop if that seam doesn't get
the rest of the revenge very well
Starbucks as a woman out for vengeance
after being left for dead by her mother
and his friends all of which is shown on
screen naturally revenge is only brutal
and extremely well reviewed thriller
this justice oh yeah this movies like
really crazy just came out this year I
think actually
yeah longtree
has been down this one I was invited to
a screening of this and I did not I
wanted to see it there actually I would
never I would never watch Antichrist
never watch later won't read up do it
again
oh darling you having a multi-year
Bantam von trier octave the director
said he sympathized with a dove headlong
Kennedy's decided to let the filmmaker
exhibit his latest picture who touched
eighteen festive well surprise the
hostage a cult is even more difficult to
stomach than its predecessor in the
movie Matt Dillon plays a serial killer
on a 12-year murder spree when if they
ask the jack belt screamed people left
not just one or two Rita reportedly more
than a hundred vegetable guests decided
to leave this theater rather than finish
watch in the aftermath the techies turn
to Twitter to express their disgust
kool-aid von Trier's movie vomiting and
claiming that a quarter should not have
been made and criticisms but they should
have expected they have to Jacqueline
yeah Stowe basis that it wasn't even
allowed to compete for the Palme d'Or
Kenneth's top prize
instead it's great outside of
competition in order to avoid any
Antichrist black contra vessels when
horror fans and affiliates as a seat by
the high attention
they received special by dragging the
bob bags it wasn't a job as fantastic
best to co-direct of Mitch tag was
posted on Facebook during the screening
at least two people pasta one of hit his
head on the stairs her mother started
pinky by the time the phone wrapped and
ambulance was on side treating various
members of the audience with illness
that's a pretty is this Raymond but is a
particularly gross move the heart begins
in Costa Rica were brought to be
receives a mysterious and sexy
she's already struggling with her
upcoming wedding domineering soon-to-be
mother and a fiance's child Phil's plans
for the future black box Williams
doesn't realize the severity of their
situation before long she's pinking up
us lay egg sack surrounded her
Department raising a hive of carnivorous
monsters and achievements at bloody
decomposes insect deform underneath
it sounds kind of cool well [ __ ] I don't
want to see this movie to finish in fact
you might find to be something of an
endurance test if you do see Death Watch
when the filmmaker says that movie is
going to make you chef Peckinpah and one
of eight the Wild Bunch widely
considered a classic
now what during its initial run through
these hot bullets was too much from late
60s movie about gifts they're very
making this is Landmaster film calling
it wasteful consent often launched gal
reeking of John Wayne complained that a
lot of bunches one sucked action quite
destroyed the myth of the alt West
[Music]
you know the night is that well thought
she's still grotesquely wired in the 90s
Warner Brothers tried to release the
directors gotten ten extra minutes
footage that you stuff was particularly
gory but the still took the opportunity
to change the Wild Bunch is writing from
an nc-17 Wow
there's a lot of movies wow that's dark
I want to see I was just like oh this
isn't another sexual assault movie this
is just something about that whole plot
that sounds like crazy
fundamentally relatable oh my gosh I
hate oh oh man that sounds super I don't
like a good body or it sound like a fly
a little bit really you know there are
some really bad bug bites out there like
my mom going and then like she had knee
pain for six months she'd come go yeah
it's a real disease that sounds funky
but it's not you don't turn into a bug
so he's good still a person look I hate
ill I Ross movies not because I can't
sit through them cuz they're so like
happen you know this is why I think
you're so flawed with your films and I
know he has a fan base out there I don't
think a lot of people will speak up for
his films invite have you seen any of Li
Ross movies he's the one who did hostile
yeah I saw like a 10-minute clip of
hostile and said I'm never watching this
he's talking about if you're really okay
if I've really done my job as a director
nobody can actually watch your movie you
don't want people walking out of a movie
you want them running out of the theater
screaming when that happens that's like
a standing see his movies aren't scary
though that's the issue that I have with
him is like totally all the whole vibe
just doesn't feel real so he settles for
like insane amounts of gore that's just
off-putting so if anyone leaves because
you're like I don't even like scariest
movie to you your favorite most
horrifying horror movie the movie that
scared me the most I mean that all
depends on age and stuff because I don't
really get scared now which is funny
you're growing up it's like you think
you'll never stop me it's here movies
but nowadays I'll watch the scariest
with the year and I don't really get
scared I get scared what's it why what's
yours
oh god I mean I could cuz my know my
favorite horror movies not really that
scary
I'm just really sensitive to horror like
paranormal activity that kind of a thing
that's gonna shadow me when I thought
yeah that was terrifying generally
speaking like any of the Saw movies I'll
just get up and I end up walking around
the room I cannot sit down and I'm just
like you know I can't handle it I can't
handle it that's why I avoid it it's
just too much of an experience I know
what you mean
I mean like what he's talking about here
what scares us is very subjective I know
people who are like I'm really scared of
movies like Halloween because that's
real you know and then for me I'm like
well weirdly I get more scared of
supernatural stuff I think as am I like
Catholic upbringing so when I see
something like paranormal activity or
The Shining or something things that
deal with like demons and ghosts that
scares me more than real life thing for
some reason it's like this is a call
goes in your mind and believes it oh
that's tough
so it's objectively speaking I feel like
the movie that probably terrified me the
most like growing up it was poltergeist
that scared me the most but yeah I don't
know a movie ultimately is the scariest
one I've seen the thing is I think is
that it's not about like oh the gore as
you're saying that you like yeah movies
it's about how the story is told yeah
it's about the tone of
vibe it is about the mood especially
like lars von trier who did like this
movie called Antichrist in the house
that Jack built
I have a hard time sitting through his
movies they are genuinely very
disturbing to me I think Eli Roth can go
even goryeo than him this is the one
would like the talking fox like his tone
is so disturbing just the tone that
before there's even any gore I'm
uncomfortable
I started his movie Antichrist and I
heard about a couple of moments of like
genital mutilation in the film I heard
about those scenes I heard very vivid
descriptions of what goes on I was like
no I might be able to sit through it and
then I started the movie I got 10
minutes into the movie and the tone was
just the tone was so unsettling I'm like
nope I'm not gonna do this I just won't
sit through that because something like
Eli Roth I can oh that's just some
stupid movie
but something like that that feels real
I'll get under my skin this movie
irreversible oh yeah what about the
sound ranges basically there's a
14-minute assault scene and it's like I
don't know if it's one shot do you buy
assault you know what I mean okay the
word that would get us no our word team
oh yeah or it is probably already like
do you monetize but yeah a in general I
just have the hardest time watching
those specific scenes and then I heard
there's like a 14 minute scene in here
that's what it's like it's most famous
scene it's 14 minutes long so it's so
and I'm like no wonder the main actress
can't watch it
oh yes Ramat izing just to film that
scene exactly then you have to relive I
don't know who would want to watch this
movie when you I've taken a lot of
acting classes and like you have the
recession for these guys movies you have
to really mentally go this you really do
and there's like two
at least that I've learned are so many
different methods but like one of them
is a substitution so you have to like
put your own memories in there in such a
way that you elicit the real similar
reaction to what the characters feeling
so yeah I wouldn't want to relive a past
thing that was horrible first of all or
there's like use your imagination I
don't know I wouldn't want to even
direct like I would never put that in us
I don't know one of the tropes I hate in
movies nowadays is and what's funny is
this movie revenge she gets raped and
then she goes in this like crazy ass
revenge spree and I kind of hate that
trope now because it's such a trope of
like she's gonna be a strong badass she
has to get assaulted first you know and
I hate that trope but everyone even
women I know who are very outspoken
against that trope really liked this
movie so it's interesting to see the
movie like this that apparently handles
it well I haven't seen it yet but I know
pretty much yeah and I heard it's like
really intense and gory that one sounded
appealing to me
well the Wild Bunch is the last one
because of it trying to be like all
[ __ ] like film Schooley about it who
actually it's the wild which is the time
period in the consideration like what
yeah it's a classic and people sit
through this movie all the time you know
I don't think that should be last
evidence is of course worst film other
any films you just refuse to sit through
everyone sit through this one called the
Serbian film which involves like the
most horrendous things I've ever heard
of put on camera there's really really
bad one Hannah Montana documentary
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I watched the Hannah Montana movie in
the theaters I think I liked the girl at
the time hostile actually that comes to
mind it's just too much more I watched
all of the Saw movies though somehow but
it's cuz my ex made me sit through them
that bastard but tape your eyes I can't
come to you to a chair is that I felt
like there were some good themes at the
end of the day and that there was some
analogies in there yeah and there's like
this there's like mystery elements that
you're like the core stuffs happening
it's not all the time I refuse to watch
The Human Centipede part two part two
but you watch part one actually I
started the first half-hour part one
then I was like I'm gonna do this I want
to stop this before we get there it's
like the idea of what it was headed just
was like nope I won't do it and then I
heard about all the craziness that goes
on in part two
there's just something that's just I
refuse to put myself through I just I
refuse because I'm the kind of guy that
if I witness to something in a movie
like that I'm gonna replay it in my head
so often and I just don't want to deal
with that I don't like yeah I'm not bad
I'm not good at like I could've gene
though so that's why I don't sit through
it for myself I figured - you've revenge
one day and I feel like I might want to
see bite the wild much I want to see
especially since Mel Gibson's remaking
this was probably gonna be ten times
more gory it's like movie woman that
sounded really weird that sounded super
weird really like offensive
the other thing movies is like I don't
have time to go watching all these
things either it's amazing I'll watch it
or it's not worth it I don't feel like
it yeah I've got [ __ ] to do
so well hey listen on that note I want
to give a patron of the Dacian special I
want to do a guy named Taylor Bentley oh
that's a good name
Taylor Bentley listen so I chat with
some people at our patreon to messages
and stuff and there was a while where he
went away because he got a new girl he
liked she was really into him and then
he stopped messaging his factory state
pledge good on you
that's a good guy right there and I
shattered him out and he showed his
girlfriend or shoutout and she loved it
so we're helping him get get some yeah
oh yes he's yeah he's waiting til I just
wanted to say man you better hold on to
her tight because what tends to happen
if like a subscribers girlfriend ends up
liking me they realize that they'll
never have someone as cool as funny as
good-looking as me so they end up
leaving said subscriber so if I were you
I would not let her watch any more of
our videos because she's bound to leave
I heard some horror stories about women
who saw the notebook and said my man
will never be like Ryan Gosling so I'm
leaving him take that apply it to me and
that's a situation you're in urine so I
would just be very mindful of that
before you start going showing her
shoutouts and if you want to start up
your own channel don't because I will
not support you man show her all the
videos touch each other to our videos
and the video editing software you know
just start with iMovie for beginners
it's actually a great program Final Cut
Pro and I yeah that's great especially
with what you can do with it now so
there you go man and you still haven't
replied to me since November 17 so quit
being a dick get on it
get off of her and get on the message it
he's holy he's not on her it has mine he
is okay what is this way Oh captain
you'd be so happy anyway guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation what's
the most disturbing movie you can think
of click that notification bell follow
cat on the world if you see her on the
road stalker
oh don't do that but you can't go to my
website Kat Alvarado dot-com slash
events and you can see when my next
shows are it is tough to be a woman
these days and I like the way you said
that
thank you we have a patreon